alright so we did our first QA ask gave
a couple weeks ago and we got so many
questions that we figured we're just
going to keep rolling with it we're
going to try to do them more often so
here we go @michael vge said I'd like
you to justify why you think that the
latest Star Wars is the quote best yet
as I disagree and rate it alongside
Hunger Games and acting and it just
seemed like a remake of a new hope but
two special effects and 3d were
outstanding okay so if you don't follow
me on Twitter which I cannot believe you
don't I did tweet that I thought it
might be the best Star Wars ever yeah
I'm talking about the force awakens so
let me let me lay it out for you when
you factor in the amount of heavy
lifting that this movie had to do not
only reboot a franchise but also make
people forget about the prequels bring
in all the old actors from the originals
as well as introduce a new cast bring in
new villains bring in new good guys make
it feel like the old one so you felt
good about the whole thing again
bringing the sense of humor and not have
the dialogue be stiff like it was and
all of that sup when you bring all of
that together on top of the overexposed
media and all of that I think the lift
was so big here that when you factor
everything in I think you actually could
say that this was the best one that
being said if you remove some of the
stuff that has nothing to do with the
movie the pressures of the actors and
linking everything together 30 years
later if you remove that I would still
say that probably a new hope the
original Star Wars is the best I know a
lot of people say empires the best i
would say probably new hope but i
thought the movie was pretty great
they've set up so much good stuff i
don't want to give any spoilers in case
anyone on earth hasn't seen it although
i saw this morning that that it
displaced avatar as the highest grossing
movie of all time but yeah it was pretty
damn awesome there you go all right
spend asked could you please give any
advice on how to counter a very popular
narrative at this moment because the
media have failed to label the Oregon
militiamen as terrorists they expose the
racism and bias towards how they portray
colored people during acts of violence
of some sort
as a white person I feel like I can't
even begin to speak my opinion about the
matter if I first don't agree with this
narrative is it possible to create a
dialogue that allows for dissent or even
a little nuance when it is such an
emotionally charged reaction of outrage
okay so this is a really great question
now I think we're going to post this
video probably two or three days after I
say this so as the moment when I'm
saying this right now no violence has
taken place right so this this armed
group of people they took this building
this Wildlife Refuge building in Oregon
apparently there was no one in the
building and it sounds like they didn't
even have to break in they just took the
building i'm not defending the actions
in any way but no one was actually
terrorized and actually taking the
building and at the moment there seems
to be no threat of violence I've seen
the guys on TV and they're saying that
they're not intending to use violence
unless the government use violence now
at the same time the government can't
just sit there and let people take over
a federal building so perhaps violence
will come out of this it makes it
extremely hard to talk about one of the
things I I tweeted I googled the actual
definition of terrorism and you know it
talks about intimidation and violence so
maybe if you change that from
intimidation or violence while you have
intimidation here because these people
have weapons they haven't done outright
violence yet but I suppose you could
argue that taking over a federal
building even if no one was harmed and
there's no hostages or direct threat to
any citizens is an act of terror I mean
the one thing that I really see in this
thing is that of course the lines are
being drawn if you don't like these
people and you don't like you know what
they stand for of course you're going to
hate what they do and want to call it
terror and you know the reverse goes for
the other side I think it's important to
just actually learn about what these
guys want which I'm in the process of
doing myself right now okay next up at
Chris our gun with their aggressive left
in power positions in big organizations
like Wikipedia and Twitter places that
have a stranglehold on information and
how we share it do we really have a
chance to dismantle the narrative I mean
this is obviously a great question
because the regressives the ideas of the
regressive seem to be big in a lot of
the Silicon Valley places right so I
think the best thing you can
do and this is how I would answer any
question related to the regressive left
hand by the way I got a zillion I got a
zillion Star Wars questions but I got a
zillion regressive left questions I'm
happy to mix it up to but i would say
you answered anything related to the
regressive left the best thing that we
can do is say what we think is share
videos that it that are explained how
you feel about things share memes share
your ideas because they can't silence
everybody right and you know their their
ideas and their attacks of bigotry and
racism and all the stuff that we talked
about all the time have become so
insincere that they're worthless at this
point so you just got to keep sharing
what you think and sharing the right
liberal ideas if you're liberal and if
you're not if you're conservative and
you want to share some ideas share those
ideas whatever you are share them and
and let the best ideas win Dylan asks
would you be willing to have an academic
scholar of religion on the show what do
you think of the secular study of
religion and academia of which I'm a
part of I absolutely would you know I'm
a little conflicted about the religion
thing because we've talked a lot about
religion here I don't even care that
much about religion I think we should be
governing ourselves on secular values
that that should be clear to you guys at
this point right so I think the more we
focus on religion were actually giving
too much away to the religious when we
should really be focused on how do we
govern a secular society and care about
the laws of the land and the
Constitution and care about our
individual freedoms and that kind of
stuff that being said because religion
is important to a lot of people and it
helps define how they live their lives I
would definitely be interested we've had
obviously a lot of atheists on but I am
looking for people from the faith-based
community and I have a couple in mind
from a bunch of different religions so
stay tuned for that Andrew said is there
a difference between watching your show
on aura or watching on YouTube I address
this once in a video a while back so
yeah everything being equal aura is our
home or is producing the show or which
was co-founded by my friend Larry
King and they're producing the show and
you know all the promotion that I do for
the show on Twitter and Facebook and all
that is to get people to watch on aura
the one-hundred-percent truth of that is
that if you guys watch on aura because
aura has their own sales team it makes a
lot more money per view and then we can
do more with the show I'm not paid per
click I assure you but that would help
out in that way we really want YouTube
to just be the the sort of promotional
side of it but we know that a lot of
people watch here so we've just been
putting so that we put stuff on aura a
lot of people watch there that's great
we put stuff on YouTube knowing that
allow do you just want to do it on
YouTube that's cool too we're doing the
podcast thing we're on iTunes however
you get it you get it if you want to
watch it in all places that I suppose
would be ideal at sands 10 underscore
what is your favorite anime be honest
you know i'm not a huge anime guy which
may sound surprising to some of you guys
because you know i love like all the
cartoons & toys and all that stuff but i
will tell you that my favorite animated
movie of all time this is not anime but
it's an animated movie is the 1985
original transformers movie this is way
before Michael Bay grabbed a hold of
this thing and destroyed my childhood I
just heard this week by the way that
he's doing number 5 but then he's going
to let it go after that thank God but
the original transformers movie is a fan
tastic the animations incredible the
soundtracks incredible it's I cried in
the movie theater I saw it in the movie
theater and cried my grandma took me
with my brother I cried in the movie
theater something some bad stuff happens
they can't mean they kill people it's
dirty it's dark but it's just a great
great movie okay and finally at Arcadia
div what's Ruben reports five to 10-year
plan alright well look we want to get
this thing on television right we're
doing the digital thing right now you
know we're on roku and as I said in the
question before you can watch us on or a
TV you can watch us on youtube the
podcast and itunes in all those places
but ultimately look you still I still
not you maybe you too but I want to get
this thing on television I want the word
to spread about what we're doing I think
we're having important conversations and
I think thing we're having conversations
about things that people
want to hear about and people are just
tired of the same old crap that's on
television and this like endless battle
between oh you think this and you think
this unless just yell about it and fight
with each other people are sick of it
they actually want to hear about ideas
so I think however we can get that
bigger and wherever we can take this
thing that's what we're going to do
anyway thank you guys for doing it you
can always play along its at Rubin
report on twitter facebook com / Rubin
report or a TV / Rubin report iTunes
just search Rubin report I just said
rubén report a thousand times and we'll
probably do this again next week all
right